now we've been doing something kind of
fun on our show we've been bringing out
a live chicken to predict the outcome of
some of the games yeah now this is a
true story we brought her out to predict
games two three and six and I am NOT
making this up
she was right every single time three
for three
since we're taping this before the start
of Game seven I figured why not bring
her out one last time we know she's
going to be right please welcome back
chickpea the World Series predicting
chicken
[Applause]
[Music]
yes that's a real chicken now as you can
see we've given chickpea two helmets
full of chicken feed to choose from
whichever helmet she eats out of that's
the team she thinks will win Game seven
of the World Series let's see what
chickpea does and chickpeas headed over
to the San Francisco Giants a might be
they Joe wait a minute Kansas City
Kansas City wait a minute
chickpeas thinking thinking she's
thinking for a long - what's this we G
board
[Music]
something huh is she going to kiss
filling up be sickly we need you to make
your prediction in English what's that
what's wrong chickpea you say you've
accidentally some of an evil spirit with
your EG board
that's ridiculous yeah look
Oh
believe it it's it's demonic Colonel
Sanders
hey there chickie I got a prediction on
my own I'm gonna eat you for dinner
inhale where did chickpea go
[Music]
he is getting away
go chickpea go well chickpea got away
it's too bad she never got to make her
World Series pick wait a minute look
[Applause]
kansas city's gonna win Game seven
[Applause]
Oh incredible really incredible what an
amazing series of likely events
well chickpea did predict the Royals
will win it all tonight I think that's
what's gonna happen but I do wonder
where chickpea went wow what a chicken
games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you yes you're right that was
incredible all right
you